你是不是也遇過這樣尷尬的情況
你用AI工具想生成一個合成罩
結果臉完全就變成一個人
還越生越不像
不只不像,而且還有點恐怖
這...是誰啊?
嗨,大家好,我是大友
今天要帶大家看的就是
Google最新的Nano Banana深圖引擎
它能保留你的臉不要失真
重點它還有非常多種應用情境
你統統都不用擔心你的臉會崩壞囉
我们今天就一起来看看这九种应用吧
好那要怎么使用Gemini呢
有很多种方式
那今天就跟大家介绍两种方法
那第一个呢就直接在Google搜寻
Google Gemini G-E-M-I-N-I
这样子叮就可以了
第一个这个就是了
点进去之后它就会叫你登录你的那个Google帐号
那就选你的帐号登录就好了
第二种方式大家也可以搜寻
Google的AI Studio
它所有的AI功能都在上面
Stradio是什麼?是Studio啦
真實的
越拼越怪,好沒關係就這第一個
Google AI Studio,點進去
這個介面
所以Google AI Studio這邊也是可以做生圖
那這邊生圖的地方就比較不一樣
左邊有選一個Generate Media,點進去
第一個就是試試看Nano Banana,點進去就可以了
這邊一樣是我們下Prompt,就是指令的地方
第一個功能就叫做一鍵生成專業照
有時候難免在上課或上班的時候都需要做簡報
那如果临时没有专业的照片怎么办?没关系
我们就直接在这个视窗里面
把我们一般的生活照拉进来
我就随便丢一张好了
当然你的解析度背景是越干净越好
记得哦,在生成之前要点选这个香蕉
点这个用Nano Banana来生成
然后呢我们就说
将照片中的人做一张专业的形象照
像在专业摄影棚拍摄一样
然后当然穿着你可以把它改变
接着我们就按生成
结果就出来了
哇!這個深層的也太專業了吧!
簡直這隻...雖然我覺得是有一點不像我啦
但是我就已經七八十%像了
因為說實在我這張照片也不是拍得那麼清楚
但是它已經把我深層的這個身材感覺都幫我變好了
太好了
所以你看輕輕鬆鬆專業照片一鍵深層
那當然啦如果你給的照片的角度不OK的話
它有時候升起來就會怪怪的
你盡量給它正面的角度
那這樣子它就可以幫你直接生成一個專業的形象照
第二种应用方式
即时衣服的穿搭
有时候我们在网路上逛网拍
总会看到喜欢的衣服裤子或鞋子
但是又没办法亲自下去试穿
去门市看的话怎么办呢
没关系
我们可以先把这些衣服裤子鞋子
或喜欢的这个搭配
凑起来
然后请网路上的model
帮我们试穿看看就知道了
当然你也可以
衣服裤子鞋子分别拉进来
可是我觉得这样比较麻烦
所以呢
我直接到另外一个软体
把这个衣服裤子鞋子凑在一起
直接拉一张图片就好了
我们可以到一个叫做Dreamina的这个软体
大家可以看到就是这个Dreamina
连接在下方大家可以点下方连接去点进去
然后Dreamina这边有个画布
画布点进来之后就会长这样子
就有一个空白的页面
你就把所有的衣服
裤子衣服鞋子通通都拉进那个画面
之后把比例一条大条小
至少排到一个照片里看得到的样子就好了
编排完了之后你就按会出
存成JPG然后下载
就会像刚才那样有这张照片哦
好,照片拉进来之后
你只要把它写一个prompt
就是把这些衣服
都放在一个亚洲的model身上
跟生活一样的一个style的一个照片
然后之后呢
就会产生这样子的一张
模拟model在穿衣服的照片哦
但是这边我必须跟大家说
这个model身材都是
我觉得一等一的好的
应该都是175、180以上
所以看起来比例啊
穿起来的感觉是这样
有时候我们真的
如果身高不是这么高的话没关系我們大方一點,我們把Prompt修改一下我們直接再送再送出一次Prompt直接這邊多一個On a very short
我試過如果之後short
它還是會看不出來有什麼身材上的差別
所以你就要On a very short action
就看得出來如果我的身高是偏這樣55身
然後腿稍微沒那麼長的話
看起來會是怎麼樣
那這邊測試出來
就變女生了沒關係
总之我们就是要看一下
他的这个身材的比例大约是这样啦
就是我们大概知道自己穿起来可能是这个感觉
这样一个size这样就没错了
这个比例就是我们比较常见的
我们亚洲人的比例好了
当然你也可以把照片套用在自己身上
只是我套过的效果
除非你的照片是很清晰在街上拍
因为我比较没有拍这种照片
那我有试过就是用生活照
但是背景有点乱
就是我原本是这样照片
之后呢我请他帮我合成一下这几件衣服
就合出来的样子就像这样
也是ok也看得出来就是穿起来的搭配
所以其实真的蛮方便的
如果你想不到要买什么衣服穿起来如何的话
用这招也是一个非常实用的方法
第三种应用就是生成可爱的公仔照
这个是最近网络上蛮流行的
就是你只要丢一个人物或说丢一个宠物给他
他就会生成一个在电脑桌前
七分之一小小比例的这个公仔的一个照片
当然如果你想要自己去修改Prompt的细节的话
我觉得如果你的英文不错
你请TrapGPT帮你修改是可以的
像宠物它就会在旁边故意多一些宠物的罐头
那如果是人物的话
你也可以把它改成像是旁边有什么样的物件都可以
你就把这个原始的prompt丢到TrapGPT里再做微调就OK咯
第四种应用的就是人物合成照
这个也蛮常被各种的情境下去使用
就是两个人物合成在同一个画面
那比方说你一直很想跟某一位心仪的这个偶像合照
可是因为他很忙
你们没时间约
我不小心还是拥有了我们两个的合照
我想这个在网络上应该随手可见
另外一种应用方式呢
其实也蛮方便的
有时候我们旅游嘛
有时候玩得太开心的
都会忘记跟景点合照
虽然台湾人好像不太会忘记
如果我们真的忘记了
没关系
其实你看
像这次去埃及
未来如果去埃及的话
看到金字塔
我太兴奋了
忘记拍照怎么办
没关系
我就把我一张照片
再传上一张埃及的照片
然后希望它帮我合成
在阳光底下美好的一个回忆
最后我就会生成像这样子
有点尬
但是呢
这个阴影还是合成的蛮不错的
我到时候去埃及看金字塔的时候
我想我就会拍一张这个照片留念
第五个应用就是居家摆设的合成
这个我觉得真的是蛮实用的
就像之前跟大家分享装潢类的影片
其实有时候我们在买家具啊
家电的时候
就是不知道说它摆在家里的空间
跟你家里的油漆地板
或整体的风格搭不搭
这个时候呢
你真的只能靠想象
雖然我知道IKEA有些功能是可以讓他把家具放在家裡的空間去揣摩啦
可是呢
我可能還不是用得那麼上手
那自從知道這個工具我就覺得真的是
蠻直覺的蠻方便的
你一樣登入到Google AI Studio之後呢
你選選這個Build
點選進去
它下面
會有一些大家做的一些工具
我們就點這個Home Canvas
Home Canvas點進去之後呢
我們就會看到這個樣子一個可以
拉場景
跟拉这个物件的东西,场景就是你的家里的居家空的环境
那物件就是你要的家具或是沙发啊等等的
我们把空的物件拉进来之后
它就是一个空的空间,你可以摆放你要的沙发
那怎么摆呢?你就把沙发往右拖曳到你要摆放的位置
那么很明显
它就会搭配你照片里的光线
然后就会看出家里摆这个沙发
看起来是长怎么样
那你还可以再额外加一个台灯
因为他已经摆好沙发了,再把台灯拖到你想要放的位置我自己是真的觉得这个很直觉啦,利用这个功能把一些你看到的家具的样式整个都搭在你们家里面我觉得非常的方便可是前提是你当然要拿到这个家具的这种
白色素色背景图
它比较好可以帮你做去背
然后放置在这个场景里面
它可以对于有选择障碍的人来说
很好的一个视觉的一个判断
比方说这个沙发是橘色的
摆在这空间
那你觉得好不好看呢?
那如果换成绿色的会不会好看?
会不会好看
或者换成灰色的会怎么样
就是你可以透过这个拖拉拖拉的这个功能
就测试不同的家具跟不同家具的颜色
摆在家里到底什么样比较适合家里的环境
整体的搭配又会是怎样
我觉得非常的方便
大家可以试用看看这个功能
好第六种要跟大家分享的应用
一样跟装潢有关的
就是替换我们墙壁油漆的颜色
因为油漆的颜色可以大大影响了
我们整体居家环境的风格
那到底要怎么做呢
首先,我们要先知道说
这个Germanized Sent to the Prom
它到底要怎么理解我们想要的油漆颜色
所以等一下会带大家就是说
我们先把我们的
室内空间的照片先拍下来之后
下一个Prom,那这个Prom我已经把它设计好了
只是说其中有一个色号的地方
就是它需要替换那个颜色是你自己要换成你要的颜色
我们就是把我们的居家照片
拉到这个对话框之后呢
我们先跳出来
我们先把Prompt贴上去之后,我们跳出来
我们到那个油漆的网站
大家可以进去网站之后,你找到喜欢的颜色以后
你就Copy那个HEX的这个号码
然后把它贴上,贴到这个Prompt上面
然后之后你再按生成
有没有就像这样,大家可以看到像画面这样
所以不论你是想要什么颜色
你就只要Copy那个油漆的号码
Copy贴上到我们这个Prompt上面,就可以完成了
好,第七种的应用就是说它可以帮你把
完整的料理
拆解出食材来
然后把它摆放在桌子上
看起来就很像那种料理节目开始之前
或者说
已经料理节目结束之后
他想要告诉你说
做这道菜需要用到哪些食材
几克几毛呢
然后这个时候我们就可以用这张照片
来当做一个基底
所以说
如果你刚好本身是美食YouTuber
你是做料理节目为主的话
有时候你真的没空拍那些食材照
太忙了
或者说忘记拍
没关系
其实用这个参考一下
我们也在备注你真正有使用到的一些材料
资讯给他填清楚就好了
我之前不知道是哪家餐厅吃的
其实它不是肉
它这块白白的是杏鲍菇
那真的是蛮像肉
它把它切丁的大小也跟这个size也差不多
第八个应用就是人物的一致性这件事了
因为前阵子刚好我们公司在做一个小小的动画片
然后我们就测试说
在ChairGPT生成人物
然后配上动画
然后它能不能一直保持
就是人物的无关啊跟整个造型
因为我觉得Nano Banana在帮一些局部人物
不管是一个两个啊
甚至是单一一个人
他的这个转向不同的角度拍摄是做得非常好
比方说这个人的正面侧面背面
那这次我们就发现
Nano Banana它很大的一个进步的地方
就是在人物的一致上
他做得非常的好
像大家可以看到这两个人
这个时候
那个时候我光升成这两个人物
就常常跑掉
包含那个左边那个可爱的小胖哥
他就一直跑掉
然后呢
更别说合成在同一个画面里的
所以现在我看到这个画面真的是相当的感动啊
他把这个上面
他不管他的胡渣
或那个眼镜哥的那个样子
神韵通通都展现得非常的好
所以接着我就想测试
那两个人OK
三个人四个人五个人六个人七个人OK吗
三个人的时候也是挺OK的
就是他们都有在画面里
然后不同的角度
看起来也都是原本照片里的那个人
然后一直到我测到
我直接跳了
我从三个人就跳七个人
七个人的画面我觉得就
哇哇一样又外掉了
那我试着再试试看
那五个人好不好,五个人我们试试看能不能
没有变,五个人
果真你看五个人在画面里
他们又是谁啊,这两个OK,没错对面这两位是来面试的人吗?这是谁?原本我有设设这个女生然后这个胡子跟小胖哥跑下去啦 都不见了 你看但是我发现一个很好用的技巧
可以改变这个结果
你只要把每个人都放在同一个画面里
并且在上面取他的名字
这样子生成起来
他就会都符合了
那要怎么做呢 其实蛮简单的
你就是在我前面有介绍到的那个Dreaming Now的软体
把人物都放进同一个画面
然后它上面有打字的功能嘛
你就直接key他们的名字
这样就可以了
然后再存成一张照片
这小方法给大家参考使用
好第九种应用的就是商品展示图了
这个我觉得在于
如果你有开蝦皮卖场啊
或说你本身有在卖一些网路商城的话
你又没有那个时间
或你没有那个钱去请摄影师
帮你拍商品的专业照的话呢
其实这个就可以初步解决我们的问题
那怎么做呢?首先就是你当然要拍一张你的
要拍卖的商品的这个清晰的照片
或是你要把它变成产品的这个清晰的照片
背景尽量干净一点,那我这边就是拿了我的喇叭来做测试好了
我就拍了一个喇叭的照片,接着呢就贴上我们的Prom
那这个Prom 其实有非常多种类型
在做产品的时候啊,如果你是可能美妆保养品
或3C类的,或甚至其他种类的这个商品
它会要用不同风格的这个Prom 去下
做出来的效果会比较好,像大家看到这种
香水品牌,它就是会这样做会比较有质感
那如果是3C类,它又会有另一种风格
它有很多酷东西耶
既然大家都听到最后了,我再跟大家分享两个
我觉得很不错用的功能
第一个就是将你的物品转成它的那种很科技感的界面
浮起来那种科技感的界面
你可以随便拍一下你的桌面上的物品,或者说任何的物件
然后套上这个Plump 就会像这样子
你的物品就会呈现一个非常高科技感
有扶出它的名稱,還有一些
元件按鈕的說明,或是說一些功能的說明
蠻酷的
好,這是其中一種
最後一種要跟大家分享的 bonus
就是一個網路上的做法
我覺得它在自換產品,在同樣的場景或海報
你要換物件,比方說你是開餐廳的
然後你常常商品、食材會替換
你會這週是賣什麼漢堡
然後下一週會主打什麼漢堡
可是你其實主體的背景跟你的整體場景
是要差不多的,你只是平民换
跟你的照片换而已
这个时候这个功能就非常好用
它做出来就会像这样子,好像长得很像一个
程式码的东西
那你只要上传你的物品
原始的那张海报物品的照片
比方说我就上传这张这个
吐司的照片
那我就用Track GPT再生成好几个
可以把吐司替换成别种
产品的
这个PROMP
我就一次着把这个PROMP全部贴上去
然后接着按生成
它就全部幫我把所有款式的食物都全部
秀出來了 然後你就可以把它下載
非常的方便 你就不用一個一個生成
你就一次可以產出想要賣的商品的一系列的圖案
那當然很方便的是 不只是食物啊
其他各種物品啊 3C啊 或者是說女生的用品 香水等等的
也都可以套用哦
好了,那要怎麼做出這個工具呢?
就下個影片再跟大家分享啦
以上這九種情境大家都可以回去玩玩看哦
如果你跟我一樣對學習AI工具很有興趣的話
歡迎鎖定大有陌生的頻道
我會持續跟大家分享我最新的發現哦
掰掰
記得訂閱、按讚
幫我開啟小鈴鐺
謝謝
优优独播剧场——YoYo Television Series Exclusive